♫ ♫
>> Greg: AFTER SCARING THE
CRAP OUT OF PEOPLE, WHAT DOES
HAWAII DO QUESTION WRECKED
THROUGH THE FCC.
ATTORNEY GENERAL DOUG CHIN SAID
"GOOD BUSINESS MUST NOT BE
DECIDING WHAT PEOPLE IN HAWAII
CAN ACCESS ON THE INTERNET."
I DON’T KNOW.
SOMETHING TELLS ME BIG BUSINESS
WOULDN’T HAVE PLACED AN INCOMING
MISSILE NOTIFICATION NEXT TO THE
LIGHT SWITCH.
THEY WOULDN’T REASSIGN ONE
WORKER.
THEY WOULD REASSIGN THE ENTIRE
STAFF.
SUCH ARE LIBERAL PRIORITIES.
IT’S NOT SATURDAY’S CATASTROPHE
BUT THE SPEED AT WHICH CITIZENS
CAN GET THEIR CAT VIDEOS.
MY THEORY, THE DEMOCRATS WILL
FALL IN LOVE WITH RESISTING
PROMPT SO MUCH THAT THEY HAVE
PROVIDED THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
WORKING TO MAKE LIVES BETTER.
NOT WORSE.
LET’S REVIEW WHAT ELSE GETS
DEMOCRATS ATTENTION.
AS THE REST OF US FOCUS ON COP
KILLERS, THEY HOLD US HOSTAGE
OVER DACA AND WHILE THE ECONOMY
CHARGES AHEAD, THEY NORMALIZE
SOCIALISM.
WHILE THEY GIVE CITIZENS HEART
ATTACKS, THEY GO AFTER THE FCC.
DID YOU HEAR ABOUT SEAN SHIELDS?
HE HAS A DAD WHO NEARLY DIED
FROM A MASSIVE CORONARY IN
HAWAII DURING THAT FALSE ALARM
WILL HE WAS TALKING TO HIS KIDS.
I’M SURE HE IS THRILLED HAWAII
IS GOING AFTER THE FCC IN COURT.
AFTER THAT, THEY CAN TALK TO HIS
LAWYERS TOO.
KIMBERLY, HOW ARE YOU?
>> Kimberly: PRETTY GOOD.
>> Greg: JUST HAVING A CASUAL
CONVERSATION.
THIS GUY CONSUME HAWAII?
>> Kimberly: PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT IT AND ASKING
ABOUT IT.
SOME LEGAL RESPONSIBILITY, SOME
KIND OF PENALTY, FINES.
I THINK IT MIGHT BE TOUGH TO DO.
OBVIOUSLY HE COULDN’T SAY THIS
WAS BECAUSE, A PROXIMATE
CAUSATION.
IS HE GOING TO SUE THE CITY, THE
STATE?
TRY TO SUE THE PERSON WORKING?
SUE KIM JONG UN?
GOING TO TRY TO SUE
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
IT GETS COMPLICATED.
EVERYBODY FEEL SO SORRY FOR HIM
BECAUSE IT’S HORRIBLE THING TO
HAVE HAPPEN.
IT GOES TO SHOW THE SERIOUSNESS
OF THE SITUATION WHEN SOMETHING
LIKE THIS HAPPENS, IT HAS
FAR-REACHING, DELICATE
IMPLICATIONS.
>> Greg: JESSE, THIS IS ABOUT
SKEWED PRIORITIES.
>> Jesse: HAWAII, I’M GOING TO
GIVE IT A PASS BECAUSE IT IS
HEAVEN ON EARTH.
THEY CAN AFFORD -- NO >> Greg:
THAT’S HOW THEY GET IT.
>> Jesse: IF IT IS NOT THE
FALSE ALARM, IT’S JUDGES
SLAPPING DOWN TRUMP INITIATIVES.
HUGE PROSTITUTION, HOMELESS
PROBLEM IN HAWAII.
THAT’S FINE.
THEY ARE GOING TO TRY TO TACKLE
THE WRONG ISSUES.
THEY ARE TRYING TO SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT OVER ILLEGAL ALIENS.
THEY ALWAYS SIDE WITH BLACK
LIVES MATTER OVER POLICE
OFFICERS.
>> Greg: JUAN, I SAW YOU,
SURPRISE, ROLL YOUR EYES AT
JESSE.
I WILL IMPLICATE THE MEDIA IN
THIS.
THE STORY IS A BIT LIKE THE
VEGAS STORY.
IF THERE IS NO NEW NEWS OR SPIN
OR VISUALS, WE TREAT IT, IT’S
OVER AND WE MOVE ON.
EVERYBODY IS GUILTY OF DOING
THAT.
>> Juan: SURE.
BUT YOU THINK WE SHOULD --
>> Greg: WE SHOULD STICK ON
THIS.
>> Juan: THERE ARE
CONGRESSIONAL HEARINGS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE HELD ON THAT POINT.
>> Greg: THAT IS NOT ENOUGH.
>> Juan: YOU WANT THE HAMMER
TO CALM DOWN.
IT’S INTERESTING.
I SAY SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
THERE WAS NO CHAOS.
THERE WAS NO BREAKDOWN IN SOCIAL
ORDER IN HAWAII.
THIS GUY.
THIS GUY IS THE ONE PERSON WHO
SAID HE HAD A HEALTH ISSUE OUT
OF IT.
I DON’T THINK THERE WERE ANY
DEATHS REPORTED.
THE KEY ISSUE FOR ME AS YOU LOOK
AT SOMETHING LIKE THIS AND YOU
SEE SO MANY MESSAGES WERE SENT
BY PEOPLE THAT WERE LEGITIMATELY
FRIGHTENED, THOUGHT THEIR
LIVES -- THEY SENT MESSAGES THAT
ARE QUITE TOUCHING.
I DON’T WANT TO OVERDRAW THE
PICTURE ON ONE GUY WHO SAID HE
HAD A HEART ATTACK.
>> Katie: WHAT IS THE PURPOSE
OF HAVING THIS WARNING, BECAUSE
IT CLEARLY COULD BE A THREAT TO
HAWAII?
THERE’S A REASON WHY THEY HAVE
THE BUTTON TO PUSH SAYING
THERE’S A BALLISTIC MISSILE
INCOMING.
MY ISSUE IS NOT JUST THERE’S NO
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE GUY WHO
SENT THIS OUT AND IT TOOK
40 MINUTES FOR THEM TO RESEND
IT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE FALLOUT OF
THIS, PEOPLE DIDN’T KNOW WHAT TO
DO.
THERE WERE NO SHELTERS TO GO TO.
PEOPLE ARE PUTTING THEIR KIDS
AND STORM DRAINS.
IF THERE IS GOING TO BE THIS
OPTION IN THE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
SYSTEM OF A BALLISTIC MISSILE
WARNING, PEOPLE SHOULD PROBABLY
KNOW HOW TO REACT TO THAT.
IT WAS VERY CLEAR NOBODY KNEW
WHERE TO GO OR WHAT TO DO.
THAT IS THE BIGGER ISSUE,
CONSIDERING WE LIVE IN A WORLD
WHERE THIS MAYBE COULD HAPPEN
VERY >> Juan: AND THEN THEY
WENT ONLINE, KATIE.
BECAUSE NET NEUTRALITY -- THEY
COULDN’T --
>> Greg: CHECK OUT IF THE
PARENTS REMEMBERED TO GET THEIR